almost 15 minutes late we're starting a
little bit early I want to say thank you
on behalf of the Graduate School of
Architecture planning preservation for
joining us for which is actually the
second event already in eco gram three
on Africa and I won't say much I'll be
brief but it will say that this is a
really ambitious wonderful project that
Jana has brought to the school with
Mitchell joakim it started three years
ago that we really had to seriously
inject sustainability and ecological
issues into the school and three years
ago it was a one-day conference last
year it was a one-week conference and
this year they're events spending two
weeks with two other collaborating
organizations involved with us including
our friends at the audience Hall says
the French Institute who introduced us
to people who we never knew we'd meet
before it's wonderful and our friends
the Committee on global thought Columbia
University and so I I will just say that
is a on behalf of the Dean and on behalf
of the school we are so indebted and
grateful to you wanna who teaches both
here and in Parsons and she should get
some sort of frequent flyer miles for
the subway rides back and forth that
she's done but I hope you will join us
over the next few weeks or two weeks and
enjoy and anything you do miss I want to
remind everyone we do record everything
and it's on our website under G SAP on
iTunes so enjoy
thank you could I have the first image
please turn the lights down so first of
all I'd like to thank the mark quigley
for hosting and supporting this ongoing
event since 2008 on behalf of my
colleague who collaborated with the two
previous eco grams Mitch Joachim and
myself tonight's event that has
different venues and several partners
and co-presenters I'd like to just
welcome them briefly and then I'll make
four points and hand over to Fausto
first of all we're very excited and
honored to welcome the alliance
française the French Institute EF
co-hosting this evening for including us
in their wonderful crossing the line
festival I'm hoping to have an image any
moment which is a platform for artists
from both sides of the Atlantic whose
powerful practices and ideas offer us
critical reflections reflections on the
world we inhabit this year there's a
specific focus on the artists role as a
critic critically important thinker and
catalyst for social change since this is
an ongoing emphasis of the Eco Graham
conferences as I will explain shortly
when we met with the two co curators
lili chopra the artistic director and
simon Dolph director of the herberger
Institute school of dance at Arizona
State University they're both here
tonight they immediately thought to
introduce us to Faust and Lena akula's
work who will who has happily joined us
this evening I would also like to thank
the director of the african film
festival Mahan bernetti who suggested
and arranged for us that we screen the
documentary film burning in the sun by
Cambria Matlow which we did this
afternoon the committee for global
thought of Columbia for co-hosting the
panel about economy and a to be
moderated by Professor Joseph Stiglitz
next Wednesday September in 29th and
Gavin browning from studio x for hosting
Mabel's Mabel Wilson professor a tree
sap and Peter talking to exhibit of
photographs of modern architecture from
Ghana
to coincide with eco gram that opens
this thursday professor saskia sassen
helped us brainstorm and her event is a
whole day closing event cities and
nickel crisis next Friday October first
Andres lepak from the museum of modern
art who helped us bring Francisca ray
and helped us with the whole process of
the invitation who's curating the
exhibit that opens next Tuesday
small-scale big change one of our
participants is in that show and finally
last but not least my colleague been
browski for director of special events
here at the school and Lucia halogen for
their incredible energy and inspiration
in collaboration ok now I'm going to
make these 4 points 1 the concept of eco
gram in general and then the concept of
hecka gram this year this series as a
whole explores what might be an
appropriate approach to sustainability
it goes against the grain in comparison
with other schools of architecture we
think that have placed a heavier
emphasis on technological know-how for
us the question of defiling
sustainability is an ongoing concern of
these conferences the no matter what
sustainability involves there is of
course a sense of responsibility to
future generations the question is what
form will that take what are the forms
of responsibility that one could
identify specifically for you know for
this year in relation to to Africa if
ecology is about planetary housekeeping
as our dean mark Quigley once wrote what
can you tell us about home the place
where we actually live we in the North
have for a very long time neglected been
terrible housekeepers to the south this
conference is motivated by the challenge
of how we may improve that and I will
explain ecology is also about
interdependence II
he OCZ's it was a term by the stoic
philosophers think about thinking about
this conference the idea that humans
belong to a sense but it's about a sense
of community and about a sense of
awareness of others so part of the
project of this conference is to broaden
our sense of familiarity with the other
which isn't this what education is about
certainly architectural education since
architecture is entirely linked with
global social political forces and of
course economic and environmental ones
we hope to teach the students how to
become global citizens and be attentive
to the needs of others finally Africa
why Africa we all know that the demands
of anthropogenic activities are putting
on the on the world's ecosystems are
putting the world's ecosystems under
stress this is much more acute in the
global South in particularly in Africa
dr. wangai moon timati Nobel Peace Prize
winner from 2004 has put it this way in
a coat Africa is a continent that will
be hit the hardest by climate change
unpredictable rains and floods prolonged
drought subsequent crop failure rapid
the certification among other signs of
global warming have in fact already
begun to change the face of Africa end
quote Africa is of course an entire
continent in terms of language and
culture the world's most diverse the
cradle of mankind and where humans first
evolved it possesses a history searching
back the five millennia to some of the
world's earliest ancient civilizations
the conference is not meant to
centralize or claim that we can talk
about it in a simple kind of over
generalized way but at the same time we
feel that it's a vast part of the world
that we know very little about
especially in the field of architecture
why don't we know more about modern
architecture in Africa why is our
knowledge up to the vernacular but no
more one could say then that this
conference is long overdue and Mabel's
project in Peters
thursday is starting to address this
hopefully now so the Eco Graham the goal
of this year's eco Graham is to see
sustainability through the lens of the
global South particularly Africa as
regards to climate change Africa stands
out as the continent that has
contributed the least amount of
greenhouse gases even though it's meant
to be it will be the one who was one of
them are places that will solve suffer
the most in a fair world in which all
people have equal rights to the
atmosphere this should mean that Africa
has considerable rights to admit which
had not yet been exercised but one of
the perversities of climate change
negotiations is that it is the big
emitter to exercise power the e us the
EU China India and Brazil they can hold
the rest of the world to ransom in a way
but people who are most likely to be hit
the hardest by global warming have
little or no voice since they have
nothing to trade this of course raises
issues of global equity and in Africa in
very much in an extreme way and that is
an important question in the ongoing
exploration of sustainability is
sustainability more an issue of social
resilience the disruption in this
location tonight's event on the web
based looking at artistic production in
Africa so on the one hand Africa is a
place that has suffered and predicted to
sell for more as a result of climate
change on the other there's reason for
optimism given the rapid development of
places like Ghana as we will see with
Mabel show and it's something we would
like to understand a little better with
this year's conference we also want to
understand how the question of
sustainability will change what will
happen to the definition
inability as a result of looking at this
work when we talked when we met with
foul Stan and his partner virginie last
februari we were incredibly moved by his
description of of his work in creating
spaces that he calls invention boxes not
yet realized in his place of origin the
democratic-republican combo in a small
community called kisangani where he says
that he sees them as places where they
can search doubt and have performances
and we thought that this is very much
starting to show a way of a kind of
social sustainable an idea of a social
sustainability that we wanted to feature
here so in a way perhaps we could say
that vowel sounds but that the Congo
maybe is at the heart of the African
experiences it's both one of the richest
countries especially in terms of
national resources and one of the
bloodiest in terms of modern history and
political instability so how do you make
art and culture in that context and what
does it do what are its goals so we want
to situate that exploration tonight and
to understand first of all thousands
cultural project that actually includes
architecture and building and then after
Palestine talks to us a little bit about
his work I will introduce our other two
very distinguished participants
Professor Oak wien Weezer and professor
Mamadou doof who will engage in a
discussion about some of these issues so
let me introduce the here we see the
crossing the line first of all I
recommend that you try to go
see some of these events especially
especially looks okay there is a there's
an event Houston has already performed
in New York a few nights ago but there
are some urban events that our students
and architect audience might be
interested in Architects in the audience
one has to do with urban farming several
have to do with urban farming and one
has to do with bodies in space will a
donor so those will come up in a minute
and i would like to introduce falls down
dancer and choreographer Faust on Lanai
akula lives and works in Kisangani
northeast democratic republic of congo
formers a year former independent state
of congo former Belgian Congo he teaches
in Africa Europe Vienna Brussels court
cork excuse me Lisbon and in the United
States he has lived in Europe for a long
time but then as I understand from your
texts at some point in 2005 you were
visiting the US during Hurricane Katrina
right and at that point you decided to
move back you had you had a dream
perhaps you'll talk to us about it move
back to the Congo and see how you can
actually make a difference to to art and
culture there so perhaps with that I
live you first time please welcome
Fallon I cooler and
I don't know which pictures are there
hello everyone my name is pasta linea
pula I'm a dancer I come from the
Democratic Republic of Congo that the
form as I was when I was born the
country was known as I hear it was only
when i turned nineteen in 1997 that I
happened overnight that the country
changed names and since that time some
kind of I grew or developed some kind of
obsession with history of memory trying
to understand what really was going on
because then I realized that I didn't
know anything about where I came from I
didn't know anything about my country
therefore I didn't know much about
myself and with that I came to realize
one thing that besides the form you
could call dance or theater video it was
a work with all those elements may be
ultimately the best way to call myself
would be to say I'm a storyteller and in
2001 because going back to Congo was
like well was in two stages or to kiss
and Annie it went through Kinshasa first
in 2001 I realized that the kind of
stories that I was interested in or at
least the kind of stories that got me
moving were not stories from exile and
so even though I'm very much interested
in the question of exile what is it and
I even wrote some time like in 99 my
land of Exile on native land perhaps
everywhere is about exile perhaps my
only true country is my body but then in
2001 it was very clear for me that maybe
I didn't want to tell stories of exile
so please like okay I'll go back to the
Congo the country
was in war then so I could not go back
to the son Ghani which the city where I
grew up in the Northeast so I want to
ensure that because at least it was
safer and also yeah I was playing it
safe I didn't want to go and get like
locked up there and not be able to move
outside the country at least was
possible from Kinshasa and when I got to
Kinshasa I realized that also loan
wanting to do like contemporary dance
work or dance theatre visual theatre I
was alone so it was like if I don't want
to spend the rest of my life making
solos I just have to train other people
I just have to train other people who
can work with me and therefore i started
this project that we called studios
tobacco we didn't have like even a 10 by
10 meter room but nonetheless we said we
have studios we have many of them
because then the most important thing
for me was to talk of these studios and
as a mental space or mental spaces
because things are so rough socially and
economically politically it's like a
dead end and for most people not not
only young people it's like there is
only one solution is to leave the
country it will be definitely better
that what when you there Luke noon you
believe in that once you find yourself
in paris or london brussels you realize
that it's not exactly paradise as we're
dreaming of there so for me going back
to the Congo and beginning a project
which was very clear that I didn't want
to just create a company where I'll do
my work in my own corner and that's it
suit like will make like studios mental
spaces that we need to open here to say
to ourselves that hey it's possible it's
possible to be here to dream
from here to dream about possibilities
from here because one of the main
problems for us down there is that
whenever there's a problem we turn to
the outside it's either NGOs or yeah the
IMF World Bank whatever you know and and
so that's why I talk of ourselves as
being in colonial states because
legitimacy comes from outside but how
can we be here and imagine things for
ourselves you may wonder if that's dance
or if that's contemporary African dance
it was not the most important thing like
how do you call ones attempt to carve
out spaces of dreams because we need to
dream in the middle of a hopeless
situation I know that around and inside
me my heritage is primarily ruins but
how can I continue doing something there
and so the studio kavakos project began
as this space where I can meet people
who want to do dance I give workshops
and see what will happen but from the
very beginning just very clear that I'd
known it would not be healthy mentally
healthy for me to be the only one
teaching there and because i had a
network of friends in Europe I started
inviting them because again we grew up
you know I grew up in a dictatorship in
a single ranking system and so there was
this risk that if I was the only one
doing this kind of work there yeah I'll
become another Mobutu and that's
definitely not something that a dream of
so we started like
giving workshops and i divide trends and
at the same time I was working and
producing work because I didn't want to
wait either like for 23 years until
people have got enough training and you
can say they're kind of professionals
now so we can create professional work
with them so the attention shifted like
from technical crafts to the quantity of
people's presence on stage and the work
has been really around that and this was
also very important because again when
you go up you go up in a dictatorship
one of the things that you come to
realize is that individuals do not exist
there is only one individual that's the
dictator the rest you just have to
follow and so if there is anything
political about the work that I'd like
to do is maybe just that to go back to
the individual and give that space where
it's like that's why I talk of my own
dancers an attempt to remember my name
and with the name what they like about
the idea of name is that it's not only
me me me me me stuff because immediately
the name relates creates a whole web of
relationships it talks about myself in
relation to a larger picture the family
but it goes beyond my family it goes to
history for instance was like the 30s we
didn't have the family name tradition in
the Congo it started in the 30s with the
Belgian so the family name is a colonial
institution and therefore if I call
myself linea kula which is my
grandfather's name who started the
family name tradition because in 1936
when he had his first child the Belgians
had instituted this new reality
immediately I'm talking about myself but
I'm talking also about history and so
how can I work with other artists and
leads them back to that and the only way
of imagining a commune
if is it's if you have responsible
individuals who get together and so
after four years of working in Kinshasa
training creating work but also
supporting other dance artists work to
try and nurture and push them forward
but yeah again the whole idea is not to
be alone because that would be suicidal
for me and I in two thousand and five
year old I was in the US teaching at the
University of Gainesville Florida in
Gainesville and does this strange dream
I dreamt about an uncle of mine who had
passed away some years before and was
asking for water I called my mother the
following day and say hey I dreamt about
Uncle John Pierre last night and he was
asking for water what does that mean so
she went to talk to my grandmother and
they said that you need to make a
ceremony ice but you need to make a
ceremony so I was far away as that money
so but they can make a ceremony and
after that it got me thinking and I told
her genie who my partner in life and
work maybe it's time we moved from
Kinshasa I'm gone leaving a son Danny so
at the beginning it was like a private a
private thing that will go to kiss and
Annie that will be like our retreats and
when we did to work will come to this
crazy City of 10 million or around 10
million that called Kinshasa we work
from here but immediately we got to
Kisangani in September 2006 it was clear
that that was an illusion but it had to
be the world in space and now he son
Danny which is the city where I grew up
when I was growing up there I never
dreamt of being a now
test you don't dream of such friends
there because maybe today it's possible
but then it was like just not possible
you dream of a job that your mother
would be proud of being a doctor a
lawyer it's just that when I was 15 I
started writing poetry and I have the
misfortune of starting writing in
reaction to a French teacher of mine
who's like who believed that the
ultimate development for any literary
career for an African person is to
negate you to movement and so it was
like okay I don't want to be in the
negative thing so immediately you start
writing you 15 but like with the
consciousness awareness of a history of
literature a history of intellectual
thought but when I went back there in
two thousand in 2006 in the city where
even though I would never dream of
becoming an artist that I was dreaming
of becoming a professor's somewhere and
writing was like the thing I would do in
the evening and one more 15-16 were
dreaming of changing African literature
at least that very pretentious indeed
but if you're not pretentious one in 15
then nothing can ever Hoffman but when I
went back in 2006 I made a piece around
the idea of returning home after 13
years where are my friends the city is
in ruins because the war had been
through there and but the most important
rulings were not the physical ones which
was in people's heads and in the piece
there was a 14 minute video where I just
interviewed a lot of people young and
not-so-young asking them only one
question what's your dream and to hear
like a 20 year old saying what's the
point of dreaming here any
maybe tomorrow will be another war so my
only dream now is to try and go to the
bush get some damn ond make some quick
money and have fun looks like okay if
one more if I am today it because I
dreamt and choosing this city what can I
do here so the studio Caboclos project
which are the beginning was like just
yeah we have these mental spaces sudden
it was like hey for this mental spaces
to exist we need to have physical spaces
and so came the idea that we should set
up an art center and not space then
thinking about what is it that will do
in this art center just like okay it has
to be a lab for artists it has to be a
place where we can show work for venue
but it also has to be a space where we
are in a dialogue with the city what
does it mean to be or to call myself an
artist in a context like that one what
difference does it make if at all should
make any difference what does it mean to
be a citizen and so thinking about while
thinking about that I met an object
she's German that she lives in Vienna
she's called Babel Mueller and we had a
very interesting conversation and she
was talking about architecture in
relation to the city in terms of
acupuncture she said that architecture
for her should serve it should be like
acupuncture points and it's in the
relationship between these points that
it starts getting some energy traveling
across the body or across the city so
then it was like oh maybe this is what
we should do so we decided to make our
life really complicated and they will
not create not one centre-back three so
one will be dedicated to
it should be the artist lab another one
will be the public venue for showing
work and the third will be the space
where we are in dialogue with the city
and this should be in three different
parts of the city let's hope started
looking around this is like map a Google
Earth picture of the city of dis and ani
kasanga kisangani literally means it's
from Swahili it means on the island and
as you can see you have the Congo River
in the south in the north you have
another big river chopper and we meet
somewhere here in the west and the city
isn't bedroom but the city is on both
sides of the Congo River and down south
is the most populated part of the city
you have like a quarter of the
population living there between 200 and
250 thousand was it approximately city
of 1 million we don't know exactly
because the last census was nineteen
eighty four so 26 years later many of us
have died but many more have been born
so but approximately a million but this
part in the south on the left bank of
the combo river is like the most
abandoned district in the city
politicians only go there when you have
elections because you know that the
people of lubanga give you their vote
you'll be one of the five members of
parliament representing Kisangani in the
city of Kinshasa international assembly
and so at all British magics
so we said that we should have in the in
this district which is like the most
neglected part of the city the center
where we'll be in a dialogue with the
city it's like the city talking to
itself from its weakest link really and
then around this area here you have like
what used to be called the villa because
the Belgians made a very clear
distinction when they developed with
colonial cities between the city which
was the colonial neighborhood the
colonial city that's where the white
people lived and the indigenous quarters
which were called listless city and so
in in most colonial cities you have
l'ville which is here and around here
you have the individual quarters since
last CD at service and so even to date
that has remained in our vocabulary
people who live like here let's say I'm
going to the ville which is a until I'm
going to the city and and so said that
because this is like the symbolic center
of power it will be important to have a
space here and this would be where we'll
be showing work and also to have the
artist lab reading outside the city
where we can close those and just be on
in our bubble and now in the way energy
circulates between these three maybe we
could start dreaming of having an impact
at the scale of a city and also
developing three centers it was a way of
resisting the centralizing approach to
life or public life that
defines how we live in the Congo for
most people in Congo outside Kinshasa
there is nothing and that's why even in
the way we talk we in our hierarchy of
spaces you have Kinshasa as the gate you
have the inner countries I plant their
here and then you have the outside world
that we call me Kili literally it means
the world's it's as if we were outside
the world ourselves when you come to
Europe or to America finally you've
traveled to the words and Kinshasa is
the gate to the world and we have the
inner country which really doesn't exist
and even for the government everything
is concentrated in Kinshasa there is
nothing outside Kinshasa and when you
come to Kisangani if you have any
project most people would say go to my
to school because this is the area where
you have the least power supply
interruptions even though they suffer
from that as well so it's less difficult
so for us to like I don't want to come
here and create another monolithic thing
so we'll create three spaces and see how
so we have like a house for artists and
we can come and show things here but at
the same time it's important to always
be part of the city and when we here
it's not only about arts maybe through
the artists because now I can be here
and talk to you if there is a problem
with water supply I could find I could
make the contact for that easier to be
addressed with other people so where are
we at now today we bought a first piece
of land here with the studio color cause
many does not say that ninety percent of
our money comes from touring and
co-production
we do receive like some support for some
projects every now and then maybe 2 pi
to 2 back to pay for air tickets to go
to a festival but ninety percent of our
money is our own money and so we bought
the first piece of land here but already
there is a legal issues it's in court
because the neighbors which is a soccer
club claims that its parts of their land
as well so we should know in the coming
months if it's our our land or not even
though the guy we bought it from had all
the official papers but I came to
understand that it doesn't mean anything
really having all papers doesn't mean
anything then we bought a second piece
of land here and this is where we
started the architectural process with
barbell Muller and we just broke the
ground like two weeks ago right now we
are developing building the foundations
and yeah it should be completed this
week if it doesn't rain too much because
there's a lot of rain right now and
people just cannot work sometimes for
two days everything is stopped and here
the idea is to build a recording studio
because it's not only about dance or
theater because one of the things that I
realized when I went back to kiss and
lana was that music the music especially
rock music scene was like the blast not
seen that was still alive in the city
it's developed during the war and so for
me it was clear that a head to work with
them somehow
and so I recording studio was really in
order but we have so many stories to
tell that we started working with young
people were interested in video we
bought equipment video equipment so we
should also have a video production post
production lab of course nice and
theatre spaces so like here it will be
like the multimedia recording and video
space here the dance and theatre Studios
administrative block and because the
land is fairly big it's like 4,200
square meters how's that in feet over X
square feet whoever 4,200 square meters
so we'd have these four blocks here with
eight apartments so we can have artists
note gnome who'd come and live and work
there as well with that as a communal
space so right now what we're digging
foundations for it's like for the first
blog here to have the recording and
video space plus this the communal space
which should solve in the beginning as
an office and then we'll see what would
be other phases of development
and a ramp so this is Jeff whoa yeah
Jeff was like before man with his team
of six who was digging everything and
around it's really a village the village
there is no electricity on the side for
now but these are questions that will
need to be addressed with time as soon
as it continues maybe now I couldn't
hear
I would like to introduce professor oak
wien reason we're very honored to have
him here tonight he's a nigerian-born
American art critic and curator he was
the artistic director of document 11
exhibition in Germany in 1998 2002 and
the 7th gwangju biennale in South Korea
2008 he has curated numerous exhibitions
in some of the most distinguished
museums around the world including
archive fever uses of the document in
contemporary art which perhaps some of
you may have probably know the short
century independence and liberation
movements in Africa 1945 294 has
collaborated with various museums in
Munich Berlin Museum of Contemporary Art
of Chicago ps1 Museum of Modern Art New
York Tate Modern London etc his writings
have appeared in numerous journals
catalogues books and magazine magazines
and he is also the editor of a
four-volume publication of document 11
called platforms democracy and realized
experiments with truth two additional
justice in the process of Truth and
Reconciliation corolla paralyzation and
under siege for African cities Freetown
johannesburg King Sasha in Lagos we are
very very honored to have professor and
wizard join us tonight and I'll also
equally honored to have professor
Mamadou doof who teaches here at
Columbia he is a professor of history
and the director of the institute for
african studies he is a member of the
committee of on global thought Columbia
University he's a professor he leads the
columbia columbia institute of african
studies and at the school of
international in public affairs he has
thought in his native Senegal and guest
lectured in many European and American
universities he's also a member of the
editorial board of several professional
journals including the
journal of African history and his
research interests include urban
political social and intellectual
history in colonial and postcolonial
Africa please welcome professor ocwen
weezer and mama dude you've to come and
talk without
it's your house we just have to post her
down well I should say thank you so much
Your Honor for inviting me and also most
particularly for making it possible for
me to finally meet first time whose work
of further very rapidly and not only
incredibly impressed with his conception
of what is possible in Africa but also
for dinner demonstrating what that
possibility is I've had numerous
occasions to try to work with first time
but is incredibly busy of your sleep
building you know this great center well
I think the whole are no program of eco
gram is a very interesting one and
especially with the focus on Africa and
I think I don't want to look to begin
this with any critique of up with any
critique but I think the the focus on
Africa and sustainability and
development seems to me in many ways to
really has a number of contradictions in
there this connection between
sustainability development and Africa
and that those contradictions are
contradictions that many of us have had
to wrestle wait for decades and it seems
particularly now that is impossible to
reconcile
does different tensions in so far as
Africa's concern and I think that for
Stan's work there it clearly
demonstrates an opportunity for a new
topography if you will of the African
urban space socio-political space
cultural space and economic space so i
would like to really my response
obviously to this particular event short
of really not having very much to say
beyond this incredible presentation that
for stan has made is really to think
about what we are to locate for science
project and it seems to me that one
place of located is what i see as
prevalent as a new movement currently
taking shape not only in Africa but in
those parts of the world that one can
now call the off center and that is the
development of civic imagination that
for Stan's work insofar as a city of
kissing Ghani is concerned is not just
simply an art project but how artists
and differences of producers creating
new zones of production that really goes
beyond the way in which public life had
been ordered by the state or controlled
or this piece of legitimization and
legitimacy that comes from NGOs but
rather the attempt to build new Civic
structures that are not as simply
mediate in zones
between the elsewhere and over here but
creating new in a sort of you know
centers that then locates what the
imagination of the African situation
could be and obviously first on began
with this notion of of a kind of empty
space so to speak it if I put it that
way how to work in a place where there
is seemingly nothing with whom do you
work and how do you create a complex the
north cultural ecology to make what
you're going to do possible and it
strikes me that this question is not
only a question for first time but
equation for intellectuals artists
producers and organizations and
institutions in African cities
particularly in the countries of the
collapse of civic and institutional
structures in the structural adjustment
program period I'd say Africans have a
very wonderful way of taking acronyms
and really landing those acronyms of
very very suction powerful description
because structural adjustment programs
had become SAP SAP literally means that
you know to basically to SAP your vanity
to destroy to it in a sense to render
hollow any attempt to construct any kind
of complex pesos app at least best
possible to talk about these contexts in
the courtesy of South Nordic countries
on structural adjustment program and to
understand how artists and intellectuals
have tried to cope with these process of
the rasa nation
because it is in the attempt to cope
with the resignation that one refuses to
be on Exile and I think this is really
one point the second point is to connect
first and civic project with the project
of other African artists because this
was the question that was started very
clear for a group of eight artists in da
car wit facet and these were artists who
you know contemporary artists whose
trajectories constantly took them to
Europe put them to those spaces of
legitimization those spaces of Lady Tino
legitimation that it matters and so on
and at some point in the late 90s this
group of artists ask themselves the
question how can they respond to the
critical context in which they were
working in which their work would not
necessarily be to serve the global
contemporary art market so they
developed a new project which was
predicated on exchange on a transfer of
knowledge between those who lived in
l'ville and those who live in last day I
think is very important this distinction
that first on has constructed for us
between those paisas of authority and
power that deal and Lassiter and I think
it's important because I just came back
from South Africa where that you know
distinction is so starkly in a clear in
the apartheid regime where the Europe
the African city is a city that is
deeply marked by these racial violence
and political violence so how do you
make this connection between those who
the city decolonial offenders will be
under a skirt and those who live on the
Oscars are those who live on the
landscape of invisibility those are the
people who are not able to be seen so we
fassett was trying to make this
connection between themselves living in
da car and a group of villagers who live
in the Casamance region in the northern
part of senegal and the goal was not to
take out the development ilysm of ngos
in which you know you go to where you
consider to be middle of nowhere you put
a source of running water in the center
of the stuff someplace and villages with
travel three miles in all directions to
come and collect the water so it was not
about development ilysm wit versus
project was a critique of development
and therefore a critique of NGO ism and
I think it's important to sort of to
really take this from board when we
think in terms of Africa and how one can
empower things in Africa that it should
not just simply be about giving
something but really creating networks
of exchange so with facets work was
really about an attempt to create a new
network of exchange and that exchange
was about a transfer of knowledge not on
the sharing of knowledge not about
giving anything material but really
working at the core of what was lacking
in those communities which is to
revitalize the imagination as a tool of
social and political and economic
emancipation this project I believe and
I presented this project in castle in
2002 was also linked to another project
in the Democratic Republic of Congo
which is
of group Emma's group Emma's is a
collective of a rate of intellectuals
activists artists dramatic inner drama
terms who came together in the post you
know in not post mabuti during the
tender mabuti was in power in the was
constituted the group was constituted in
1989 and the group took his name from
the Bible from Prophet Amos whose
central interest was on the notion of
social justice and here again this group
intervention into the local space was
essentially about again creating ways to
reactivate the imagination so these
civic processes I see as something
really very important and knew a way of
really rethinking the paradigm of the
African cities that we've inherited over
many years again I was in Nigeria
recently in in in July and it was very
striking how the research of somebody
like REM koolhaas had become obsolete
simply because that iconography of
carriers that was replicated constantly
in the last 10 years in legos had
disappeared for some reason because
Legos has a new young dynamic governor
who aim his view resisted the notion
that a chaotic situation of Legos as it
was then was in fact the future that was
been announced for other cities and so
this in a sense was a way to sort of the
reverse this in a jinesh this notion
that the crisis that was part of the
Legos landscape was in fact his future
as was predicted and I suppose who has
in
to his credit had done an enormous an
incredible urban analysis of Legos sort
of showing different points in how the
city connected to itself but what was
left in the minds of many people was not
that analysis it was really daikin
ography of intractability and being in
Legos to see what was really going on
how new Civic developments we are
connecting different parts of the city
again brought up this question of how to
think Africa today beyond sustainability
beyond developmental insane I will leave
it here to the house maybe mama dues in
a talk can help us link up with other
possibilities of what is happening in
different parts of Africa thank you i
would like first to thank the girl for
inviting me to participate in this
discussion and for giving me the
opportunity to meet for that i have read
for steph's woken you know from a
perspective which is a perspective /
historian and a historian interested in
understanding with new processes way in
which cities in particular since
independence have been imagined and
reimagined by not only institution who
stake on one hand but also by by artist
and by city dwellers and one thing which
comes back in any discussion about
African cities with last at least 20
years is a discussion about the crisis
crisis of governance the crisis of
governability but also the crisis around
infrastructure and around the control of
a space and all over Africa the control
of garbage dirt is one of the de
not only for inhabitant but also for
artists and I think Foster has has
precisely talked about that about and
the location of these free spaces they
are imagining and trying to build is a
space to understand actually how was
sitting kisangani in this case but you
can take that car you can take Legos how
this city's breathe and precisely how
they be imagined and an imagination from
her present and one of a first shift
which is the important and he indicated
it was shift from an imagination of what
city would literally centralized
imagination the city should display the
identity of a new regime one in
nationalist Elysium to a city which is
imagined visually which is which is
painted which is more and more taken
over by its own inhabitants and one of
the first effect for sales dr. Butler
have talked about his city became a
fragmented space we moved from a
centralized city showcasing the project
of her new nationalist class to a city
which is a city of neighborhoods and
neighborhoods taking over by the
residents of enable and in many of the
African situation in particular after a
structural adjustment moment or during
the structural adjust to make moment
where basically was paid to retreat from
very specific space to control with
levira the population were in a position
to take off and reinvent it's actually
not only for space and it's where we
discussion about developments
missed an ability becomes an interesting
discussion because what tension which
many of these cities are are
experiencing for his last 20 years our
attention between what we social
sustainability on one hand and the issue
of governability who should govern
opacity who should define the identity
in particular for cultural identity of
the city and what are the actors which
are actually fighting to control the
city is one of the important issue where
artists and intellectuals are more and
more and playing a more important role
at least in with last 10 years by first
redefining ways in which a citizenship
should be exercised and one aspect which
seems to be very very important is
really the ruling which art and artists
are playing in reinventing new form of
citizenship but when new languages which
are also projected into space and
reconfiguring the space in which people
are operating and one aspect for me is
important in looking at at the work of
Foster is more tension between history
and memory history which is in many of
his African situation the history of the
state and worse state becoming a
historian without resources in many
cases ten years after independence state
and ruling classes are no longer in a
position to trace the direction but
society should head towards which is of
integration what we are living Elias
were saying is a fragment
and whisper plantation is providing new
narratives if I take the case I know
better of a case of Senegal and the case
of Dakar at this moment the most
important moment of crisis she's were
late 80s and early 90s where you now
have a kind of revolt of the youth in
the car a protesting against the you
know BB BB the mounting pile of garbage
all over the city but deciding actually
to clean up the city and using border
teen versity has a metaphor for
absolutely the corruption of with Kate
what we really experience is very
discovery of a memory which saw which is
were memory of the past against the
Nationalists memory and the process is
not only a protest of renaming the
streams but it's also a process of
embellishing bus versity not only
cleaning it up but embellishing it and
taking over and producing literally a
new language and producing a new memory
and for a historian like me what is
really interesting is precisely the new
cultures and new modes of governance
what other you know that are emerging
from a process what I call here a new
culture first I talked a little bit
about but you insisted and your work is
really about that is the emergence of an
urban culture which is no longer related
to an absence the rural culture would
say supposedly the authentic culture
Africa I think this is the first time in
the late eighties that urban African
societies are literally redefining
themselves has has has urban society and
one thing which is interesting is what
foursome was talking about the idea of
moving from a space in which your body
is contained to a space which is
redefined from your own body and where
the opening of a space more possibility
of convergence is much more important
than the type of movement which define
actually probably until the Big Sur
burnings African cities where African
have been able even for the veal but to
subvert it by reintroducing their own
ethnic and religious allegiances into a
city which was trying in some cases due
to contain them in its outskirt and what
shows it very clear we read Africa
novels but cities were dangerous space
is where the African is losing is her
values is also losing his identity and
what is interesting in project like four
strands project is precisely not only
very appropriation of these rural
resources and they recycling into urban
object but also the appropriation of the
colonial traces in versity and their
uses in a different way but depending on
the regions we are considering reactions
are different I was really interested by
a force 10 stop
but a world outside the world of the
African which is and this is his project
in comparison to the project you talk a
project of the appropriation of a space
which has been experiencing crisis for
so long and bloody crisis and in West
Africa where you know I was African
societies have been part of a larger
world but since what the Atlantic slave
trade actually we're looking you know
outside is more important it's quite
interesting that you know what is going
on in central Africa which is a kind of
process of vernacular ization of the
outside world is gone but very
differently in West Africa you know
young rappers senegalese rappers are
saying you know differently to what
force them was insisting that the car in
New York that Paris and New York our
suburbs of the car they are returning
you know this kind of specialization
insisting on ver globalization so what
explain also that these kids have been
taking canoes you know to cross the
Atlantic you know many of them drowning
which shows I think this will be very
interesting way of reimagining the past
to invent new histories and in the case
of data this reimagining lasted less
than five years 1988 you have you know
the store flooding the city which were
smelling her you cannot imagine we flies
all over the crisis with Mauritania and
a lot of killings of Mauritania in
Senegal
and senegalese in Mauritania and
suddenly overnight thousands of young
people deciding to claim upper city and
to paint the city wall painting all over
was it and new history is being told a
new narrative painted all over and as a
historian is what I was invented in I
began walking on on this reimagining i
call it reimagining of a city when i
began seeing you know on the walls
references historical references and i
try to understand wherever references
coming from what does it relate to a
space with which is a colonial and
postcolonial state which had a memory
which was what I call a technocratic
memory a memory of its infrastructure
what we were calling how do you actually
infuse a kind of sword in a city without
and as I say it lasted no more than five
years but it's reinvented for no culture
not only a painting called again you
know in relation to what you are saying
about nigra to this is a painting which
was a reaction against sango's fine art
understanding of the picture revolution
in Senegal but it's also a reinvention
of a new music before wrap it work for
senegalese we are calling vimala which
is a music which is celebrating her but
and this is also one of the most
important rupture in the way in which
senegalese men and women began actually
performing
an occupying body diversity and this
music which is the music for dance and
dancing becomes very very important and
we and again probably one of the most
important success of Senegal today is
precise around music and dance and we
inventive Italy about dance in Senegal
is something which is unbelievable
because precise obviously discovery
Murray discovery of a body and this is
for the first time you know these years
between 1990 and 2000 that for the first
time the body of a man is displayed on
the wall and portrait has a beautiful
body the body of a wrestler with finally
adopted has a nickname Tyson but he is
interesting and I will conclude that he
was interesting because he represented
an idea of the outside what worked every
time he was actually wrestling the
stadium will be divided into two camp at
camp which is supporting Tyson and we
were vain American flags and the over
camp which is were Senegal is one people
waving celebrates flies we chose
precisely retention which is retention
which is defining today many of those
African cities and we fact that today
different groups in different fragments
of the city are not necessary
reinventing with
he had such but I reinventing new
neighborhood with a new language which
is the language which is attaching them
to both the local and global
if you have if you if you would like to
say something and then open it up to
questions well hearing these
perspectives from other parts of the
continent is really yes a gives more
energy to something feel less alone and
it's so important not to feel long as
it's not easy direct for our project for
now we carry everything on our on our
shoulders as as a structure the studio
callicles and so here knowing that
somewhere else on the continent but
definitely beyond there are other
experiences you can relate to that's
first point that's really a very
encouraging
maybe just want to read something here
this is a text from 2005 I think I was
invited to teach in Cork in Ireland and
just before that I wrote the text and
somewhere there it was like how do I
walk to myself to my people while my
when my blood is on fire and my history
in ruins one possible answer I said it
earlier on land of Exile native land
perhaps everywhere is but exile perhaps
my only true country is my body are thus
survive like a song that's never been
written another possible answer now that
we've met in this space comrade let's
stop for a while and sit side by side
I'll tell you my name and think my
national anthem I walked over I remember
of it and you tell me yours then we'll
go our separate ways leaving behind a
fragile signed our presences like
shadows in dust is this dance is this
art is this contemporary African dance
how will I know if this is art do you
call out once attempt to resist to the
cycle of destruction by planting seeds
of beauty seeds of dreams in a hopeless
context what then when this resistance
is written in one's body the body as the
last shield for freedom ok now I'm going
round and round the same circles I feel
confused and lost i guess i have to shut
up now enough of this utility
contemporary African art my foot in any
case I don't give a damn about Africa
whenever I write it strictly for myself
for a few funds and to appease the
course of time that's a quote from jorge
luis borges my time why the hell should
I care about Africa my portion of Africa
doesn't care
me years of war wait women epidemics
with millions killed that's my legacy
for my father's at best I'm left with
some energy to survive on my heap of
ruins independent state of congo
democratic republic of congo republic of
zai king leopard the second Mobutu lu
member fine if Africa doesn't give a
damn all that matters is whether my
grandmother cares for I know how strange
an animal contemporary creation is the
question is how can I create a sense of
identification with such a weird medium
could that cushy my grandmother ever say
after say my dance well I don't
understand anything and yet I work with
method so my dance will be an attempt to
up spaces of encounters
this discussion and the response is
incredibly profound and thank you very
much for opening up these issues for us
and I'm very much hoping that we'll
continue thinking about them for the
rest of the program series and right now
I would like us to like to see if there
any excuse me any questions from the
audience I know that a lot of these
issues are very very interesting to
architects specifically specifically
issues of urban space and so are there
any questions yeah
to make a new building for the Art
Center and whether the other two points
that you're talking about are you going
to be going into existing buildings or
they're both or all of them restructures
that you need to build what because the
country today is not even in a process
of reconstruction we just need to
construct everything everything has been
destroyed so definitely there will be
new buildings but for now we begin with
one and in fact like just a first module
in that one we cannot fund everything
anyway because we turn on our own if we
have to find everything to take maybe 15
years to complete and so later on we
should move on but definitely it has to
be new because there is what can you do
one its ruins how do you keep going
standing it's done already but then
everything is down this is actually a
quote from a writer from Congo
Brazzaville soon elaborate on see he
wrote to caltrain translates everything
was down even the earth was down but the
people were still there
I would like to ask more dance related
question if I may I saw your beautiful
performance with Raymond Hoke the other
night called San tita and I was
wondering if you could say first time a
few words about how that work connects
to the concerns you've been talking
about here well this work by German
choreographer Ryan mantra girl I
collaborated there in to work as a
performer relates to my own work in my
own concerns and in that ramones has a
remote work his known place now it's
been shown in the u.s. that for the past
15 or 20 years in Europe this is work
that has been dealing with the question
of memory and history and how do you
deal with those questions and how do you
find the strength to continue with your
life from wherever you are but what I
find interesting about ramones response
to those questions is that it's the
sense of openness that he gives work
brings forward and so you have this
really so it goes it's like a space for
entering into silence and this basis
that you're trying to create in the
Congo maybe because Kinshasa even kiss
on Danny it's a very noisy space I have
a friend who wrote that we are really
afraid of silence because maybe so many
ghosts come up so we need to make as
much noise as possible
because we don't want to face our ghost
and yet I think that if we can be able
to look into ourselves and build with
our fears that could be a way forward
and so the work with Raymond reminds me
of the necessity for those spaces for
silence and for stillness which for a
dancer would put some good sound from
the onset slag paradoxical how do you
aim for stillness when you're a dancer
but maybe that's like the ultimate dance
so that's a really at a very intimate
level but also that can translate in the
word price we approaching it there just
make this a very quick comment which in
a relates to force turns in a center and
they attempt to locate the center in
three different places and I suppose and
following up with what Mamadou also said
that this really isn't a tent a demand
for complication in terms of how we
think about the African city you know
because on the one hand I think you know
the city making initiatives oftentimes
really focus exclusively on
infrastructure and not in terms of
Africa today what we deal with our
deficits but not in terms of these
cellular relationships that continuously
need to be emphasized because of the
constant ruptures of violence that have
made cities you know really not about
city making but about nation making
because the think about African cities
is really to think about national forms
not about urban forms and this is
particularly important when we remember
that if we counteract the notion of
laville and la cita the native quarter
which is la cita the place that far non
describes where you know the natives
live and Laville where all the garbage
disappeared into into the you know the
garbage boxes so when we really think
about this the reason why cities become
centers of contestation for the national
forum I think it's important to set up
to take this up because this design is
spreading out of the three locations
seems to me to be one way not just
simply to remake the city but really to
create a conduit for different forms of
national negotiation and in a place like
the congo democratic coupler Congo which
has been really embroiled in decades of
internecine warfare warfare of different
grades ethnic warfare never would work
there all of that this conception of the
three locations for me suddenly I mean
is it's this is a flash of something
that is really quite important that it
takes a leap over the ways in which we
think the urban that is here is the
national that is being imagined and it's
really quite amazing to me as if you've
paid attention to nowhere
you know so just like in France today
the expulsion of the aroma is not about
the city is about the nation it's about
it really the national body so this
notion of the city that is embodied in
the work of first time is something that
is really quite powerful one way to
think about it because is one thing that
can never be dispossessed you can this
possessive physical space body embodied
in a space can never be dispossessed
unless you know a body that gets killed
so I just wanted to make you know this
connection between the national forum
and the oven form and the constitution
of these linkages in the three centers
and just in relation to the body as I'm
listening to you talk one thing that my
looking through the history of the
country but history in general one thing
that I'm beginning to realize is that it
can be studied under the prism of like
how the violence against the body
revolves different forms of violence
against the body and in a country like
that one where even though it's called
Democratic Republic speech doesn't
exactly circulate in the public space
therefore leaving all this huge space
for rumors because that's like the only
discourse that can exist the bodies
begin to play an incredible roll it
invite trying to define no new spaces of
freedom new ways of saying what words
cannot say and therefore as a dancer
that's really like an interesting locus
of exploration
one last question benson's Mabel hey um
I just had a question you were speaking
before about how whenever there was a
problem in Congo that the people would
look externally for solving that problem
what it was IMF or World Bank or
something like that I guess my question
is somehow how do you envision
architecture and dance whether
separately or together in parallel that
they would take or provide a whether
it's a platform or a route where somehow
the people of Congo can kind of
internalize and give themselves the
power to sort of take on the problems
and solve it for themselves and you
spoke about something about like nation
building a nation is there may be a
nation dance or a nation architecture
that needs to be created or is it
providing a safe haven or how do you
envision what are the roles of
architecture and dance and providing
kind of I guess I'm it I'm assuming for
taking congo forward to position where
they feel that it's we don't need
external health kind of thing okay first
of all it cannot I'm not imagining this
at the scale of the country but you're
talking of smaller scale which is that
of a city and inside that city and this
is something that like when I look that
the independent the history of
independence movements in in Africa in
general it was not the mass you had a
handful of people who started to
understand what was going on and they
could lead out of people to some places
so what you're seeing what now today I'm
hoping that these spaces in Kazan
any who provided would be like a space
where new ways of thinking oneself as a
leader could emerge and if you have 23
people who can continue this that's
already a force but it's a bad scale and
maybe it will take a hundred years to
start thinking but then I'll not be
there to see thank you one last we will
take one last question from Mabel was
hello thank you I it was a really
fantastic panel and I think the things
that you're sort of bringing forward
about the future of the you know the the
African city but I think the question of
the urban in general which isn't just
African but i think is a global question
and and actually fast and i think you
answered the question I was going to ask
you which was about the role of memory
in your project because I do think that
there is something about the way in
which history becomes a kind of but you
know sort of a structural ization of
past pneus by the state so that history
does become the grand narrative but I
think you beautifully described as just
layered up by names and in monumentality
which can also be with for architects
the kind of monumentality of modernism
and I'm wondering in what ways does
memory begin to operate both within
space and then perhaps between those
three points that you mark on the map
how do bodies move between those three
places how does the city's start to
merge out of the ability to kind of move
between those three X's that then
perhaps become habit and everyday
experience and in memory and perhaps
knowledge that then is passed on and
maybe that is that part of the plan
the gentle gentle during the war at some
point all costs disappeared from the
city because the work either taken away
by the military from the people of those
simply no gas so and then people
remembered that bicycles were very
actually very sustainable means of
transport later that no pollution
whatsoever the third and so they were
transporting everything and so human
bodies and goods everything on bicycles
and we call them talika you translate
literally by let's move on but then the
taluk east for the as we call them they
call themselves the Kalam another combat
on the fighters think
that's
seems to make like a way of responding
to the context and finding ways to
circulate in there like right now we're
not waiting for instance for these
centers to exist to begin occupying that
city so like in 2007 I received this
award from the Dutch royal family it was
100 100 thousand euros from the prince
claus fund so decided that seventy
percent of that money should go into
acquiring equipment sound lights and
video equipment so that you can start
doing stop there and so right now we
rental house in the middle of the hill
where we have our officers storage
spaces but also recording studio but
then we staged events in the city and
like around the 50th anniversary of
combos independence we organized an
event which we called three days for 50
years and it was like a way for us to
revisit historical important spaces in
the city to take our bodies their stage
events free events because the people
kissing on ebay me differently any way I
can I make my money outside Congo they
feed me differently so that's the only
thing to show appreciation is Bush stage
three events and by the simple fact of
like organizing a very important event
on the left bank where nobody goes and
this was like the first time those such
an event it was in the ruins of the
railway station and it was broadcast
live
on a new local TV station people decide
no this cannot be lubanga it was the
neighborhood is called you Bunga this
cannot be labanda this is definitely
something from Kinshasa and then people
are calling this station site is this
really noble knight like yes and and so
getting people from the right bank to go
to the left bank and see that hey
something interesting can happen also on
this side because one year by the river
and you look to the left bank in at
night it's dark there is no electricity
there there is electricity on the other
side so that's like already a way of
beginning to occupy physically and to
get somebody's to crisscross and move
and meet when will that take us don't
know I think one interesting aspect is
Denver State is no longer controlling
the space and in some cases the space in
every state is not interested at all on
one hand on the over people are
investing this cotton coat liberated
space and producing their own narrative
i think is why what for say is doing is
important is the opening of space and
the possibility for people to produce
their own narrative and search narrative
are against the meta-narrative we're
going to to take a case of senega you
know the old president of senegal just
no delete this huge crazy you know the
monument of the africa renaissance 70
million dollars you know which is
completely crazy you know the man look
like a korean holy Russia hahahahaha
woman look like a French woman and you
ask yourself what does it mean but it's
precisely whatever that that they no
longer this president has does not have
a space for a narrative which is
acceptable for the population what does
it mean it means something which is
simple
the imagining of a nation of the 60s was
a unitary and authoritarian imagination
but new one is why the multiplication of
spaces is so important is a pluralistic
imagination and we have to rediscover a
history which is not necessarily a
history of converging but the history of
conch of conflict and negotiation and
keep negotiating that is today what one
of a lesson we are learning from from
from artists which are trying to
understand and participate really in the
creation of what you were calling with
this new Civic imagination this might be
a good place to end I wanted to thank
our participants may be and with with
the final sort of note or thought of
that I had by listening to you thinking
about the vowel sounds incredible in a
way artistic kind of generosity and what
can that is there some model there that
we as architects can you know can use
and perhaps think about that there there
could be new practices that might not
hold development and sustainability
completely aside but but that they might
start to kind of overlap in new and
interesting ways and I think that that
may be a thought that we keep now for
that opened up tonight but for the rest
of the conference thank you again for
incredible presentations and discussion
and see you thursday at studio x thank
you very much